companies in industries like software
food and clothing are shifting towards
more eco-friendly business models number
of companies with sustainability goals
rose 17% from 2012 to 2017 the use of
recyclable and natural materials is a
trend in the footwear industry
particularly all birds and naik have
been doing this for years and Reebok is
now making a shoe entirely from natural
products first on CBS this morning
DeMarco Morgan shows how Reebok is
stepping towards sustainability tomorrow
good morning good morning last spring
Reebok launched its plans for a
sustainable sneaker and I'm wearing a
pair actually this morning they're
pretty cool the upper part is organic
cotton and the sole is made from corn
you heard it right corn what people we
spoke to say some fitness companies have
prioritized sustainability before and
it's not always a success is there a way
to make a suit that's made out of corn
sexy yes so sexy comes down to design we
used a silhouette that we knew people
already loved and we made it out of
these new materials for five years bill
McGinnis spent countless hours here and
what Reebok calls the maker lab where
did you guys sit around the table and
say okay you know what we're gonna try
this we're gonna try corn and cotton it
didn't start out with corn and cotton it
started out with recycling compos'd
ability where do we want to land our
issue with recycling is you recycle
plastic it's still plastic but you're
not getting rid of the problem 20
billion pairs of shoes are produced
annually and roughly 300 million end up
in landfills and the idea is how do you
how do you get rubber and plastic out of
the process and replace it with natural
things that grow like corn this isn't
the corn that ends up on your dinner
plate it's typically used to feed
livestock after its harvested the court
is milled and fermented into a bio-based
product that is eventually molded into
this it looks like feels like and wears
exactly like rubber but it's based on
corn and it's durable yep very durable
why did it take five years when you want
to make your shoes out of something
completely different
there's no vendor that you can go to
that has something ready for you to work
with you have to invent it is it
biodegradable it's not biodegradable yet
so this version is made from things that
grow so this is sustainable because of
what we make it on of which is cotton in
core there been some fails when it comes
to eco-friendly products USA Today
reporter Charisse Joan says sustainable
products can be a tough draw for
companies Mumma had a line called in
cycle which was recyclable backpacks and
track suits and people were not coming
to their stores to get it so after a
while they finally had to discontinue
the line so again it's really important
that the lines look good as well as do
good the idea is to have a long-term
commitment we know it's the right thing
to do it fundamentally makes sense to
everybody in our company
Millennials want companies that have a
social conscience and care about the
environment or the story now the moment
of truth I am ready
see it feels good feels light it's
pretty sweet
doesn't feel like I'm walking on corn I
tell you that it will certainly does it
the cotton in corn shoes are available
online today and are selling for $95 in
the same price range of the classic
sneaker and a Reebok is working on the
second version of the shoe that will be
compostable so you'll be able to bury it
in your backyard it will turn to dirt
you grow more corn and make another shoe
yeah it's a good walk around shoe it's
very good-looking it is I wouldn't run
in it but it is like sleek something you
can be cool and show a little swag so
leisure wear it really not LeBron James
or linen not at all I wouldn't play
basketball but I definitely go out you
know have a little future ankles there
did you got up with some cocoa butter or
did you deliberately wear your pants
high waters today so we could see you
know what are you starting a new fashion
alright you know what I got a very just
a little bit so you can focus on the
city question Gail are you wearing socks
i'm not wearing socks i think you can
wear them without socks and guys that
was surprise for you i actually got a
pair for each in every 100 in your size
you know I wear size 10 we found okay we
have our ways Marco and his core now
America